what is going on everybody and welcome
to my supercomputing series my goal here
is to just get you all familiar with the
ideas and concepts of supercomputers and
then I'll actually show you all how to
build a supercomputer step by step for
as little as 80 dollars but probably
more like a hundred and twenty dollars
if you don't have all of these supplies
so that'll be fun but first we need to
know a little bit about what it is
exactly
supercomputers are why people use them
and so on so supercomputers have been
around for a while they were first
introduced in the 1960s but they really
had very little purpose to them
initially they just had a few processors
kind of tied together though by the 90s
there were you know supercomputer setups
with thousands of processors nowadays
we've seen supercomputers with tens of
thousands or even hundreds of thousands
of processors that comprise them so that
gives you an idea regarding you know the
growth and evolution over time the main
idea driving supercomputers is this
notion of parallel computing parallel
computing very simply just means
calculations that are being solved
simultaneously and they're kind of it's
almost like they're you're solving I
guess more in depth the ideas you're
taking a large problem or question and
then you're you divide it into a bunch
of little or littler smaller parts and
questions or calculations and then each
node or a computer comprising this
system is tasked with one of these
smaller bits to the problem at a time
each node is served with a different
problem and fed new ones as they finish
and they kind of work in a synchronized
fashion parallel computing has actually
come up in the past in my videos here in
the form of machine learning it's based
on the same principles we're breaking
down the problem and solving that
problem simultaneously in its parts is
usually more efficient than attempting
to solve that same problem linearly so
some calculations can be done at the
exact same time where they don't really
rely on the previous solution before
they can like begin the calculation of
the next part of the problem so
got linear computing and parallel
computing so linearly it would just be
step-by-step literally and parallel
computing is where you've got multiple
computations happening at the same time
so solving a problem using parallel
computing is just also simply just more
realistic and when it comes to like
complex modeling or even things like
genetic programming where it literally
the problem you're trying to solve is an
interaction between multiple variables
at once and so when you have problems
like that it just not only is in reality
is it the case that you've got multiple
variables happening at the exact same
time so not only are we trying to like
more accurately depict certain scenarios
but also it just makes it's actually
easier to calculate these kinds of
problems with a supercomputer so some of
the larger fields that use
supercomputers are things like medicine
quantum mechanics weather research oil
and gas exploratory research that kind
of stuff with medicine one of the more
popular applications to supercomputers
is actually called folding so today
folding can actually mean a few things
but the original term folding in a sense
of what's called folding at sign home
comes from the simulation of protein
folding so you can actually donate your
computing time and power to folding at
home which is where you're aiding
basically in disease research and other
forms of molecular dynamics research so
it's kind of neat that you can donate in
this fashion rather than your dollars
and so on this was really one of the
first ways for people to donate in CPU
time and energy so now we actually have
Bitcoin which allows you to do this for
literally anything you can imagine since
you could generate the Bitcoin and then
simply didn't donate the bitcoins that's
pretty neat so the purpose of
supercomputers again solve a complex
multivariable problem by breaking it
down into tiny parts and assigning
separate nodes to each part along the
way so what is one reason why this is
superior well besides the fact that like
literally it's easier and more efficient
to model a
problem like that by actually breaking
it down and solving for each of the like
you know parts another reason why this
is actually useful is like when giving a
computer a problem to solve sometimes
the solution to a problem will require
waiting on a solution from another or
the problem is solely let's consider a
six core processor for example so like I
have an i7 3930k and it's got six cores
well if one of those six cores is
waiting on one of the other cores to
finish its calculations so it can take
that variable and use it in the next
calculation you're gonna have what's
called an idle core it's gonna be
sitting there waiting so if you have 1
out of 6 cores that's idle you're 16%
idle let's say though you have 64 6 core
processors if one core goes idle
that's only one out of 384 or 0.2% idle
so these numbers might not sound like
very much because like if a CPU gets an
idle state for just a moment it
literally is just in like milliseconds
right but how do we've actually you know
measure performance of supercomputers
the performance of supercomputers is
actually measured like for example this
i7 3930k processor it pushes out
somewhere in the 120 to 150 g flops or
gigaflops so what's that mean so you
might hear G flops or gigaflops but
nowadays as far as supercomputers are
concerned you'll hear most likely
petaflop but also there's teraflops
so petaa equals quadrillion tera equals
trillion and Giga equals billion so an
i7 3930k pushes 120 to 150 G flops so
what the heck are GFLOPS well G or Giga
it stands for what we just described
here Giga is billion tera and so on well
flops stands for floating-point
operations per second now don't get too
confused because sometimes you'll see
all caps flops and then you'll see FL
Opie and caps and s underscore
underscore under K store lowercased they
are they do mean different things
so flops
all uppercase means floating-point
operations per second and then just FL
Opie uppercase lowercase s actually just
means floating-point operations so it's
not necessarily denoted by per second
because actually to calculate flops you
use flop like how many flop plural s did
you get so anyway moving along so 120g
flops means we're getting 120 gigaflops
or 120 billion floating-point operations
per second well that sounds nice but now
it's time to consider architecture see
CPUs traditionally have been built for
more of brute heavy lifting computing as
time goes by we're seeing CPUs really
getting tape being coming taken over by
their cousin who has been pretty dormant
for a while when it comes to
high-performance computing the GPU the
name graphics processing unit might not
be the best name for it anymore since
the GPU is now being used for far more
things than just graphics now the term
GPGPU is floating around now which
stands for general purpose graphics
processing unit so what gives well it
turns out processing graphics over the
years has prepared the GPU for
processing or other processing tasks of
this age right so any form of animation
on a screen is actually the result of
redrawing right and frames that's where
we get framerate so each movement you
see is it clearing and then a redrawing
onto your screen if each pixel is gonna
be calculated sometimes it's not by
pixels sometimes it'll be like a model
itself and there's multiple models but
in the end it's broken down by pixel so
it's gonna be calculated in each pixels
position let's say is often contingent
on many other variables so today's high
performance games like take battlefield
for example they're gonna use really
intense physics engines that calculate
everything here
imagine how much physics and
calculations and variables come into
play when calculating let's say an
explosion right so that's kind of why if
something explodes in battlefield 3 if
you've got or 4 if you've got kind of a
poor graphics processing unit that's
you're gonna you're gonna start lagging
because your frame rate goes down so all
these variables
depending on other things like physics
modeling you know gee what's that sound
like alright the supercomputer is
parallel computing that's exactly what
we're looking for here so the i7 3930k
processor six cores
runs five hundred and seventy dollars
new gives you a high peak of 150 G flops
Giga flops let's poke around here now
find it GPU let's see if we can find one
for 570 well the Radeon HD 7970 is gonna
cost you about five hundred and fifty
dollars so it's close enough that will
give you about three ish for teraflops
not gigaflops teraflops so we're talking
quite the step up and that's all
basically an architecture how is this
thing set up and all that so notably
GPUs or GP GPUs are far more popularly
used in supercomputers as well it's just
like heavy processing so if you get on
like an AWS and you need like a
processing server you're probably
actually buying a GPU not a CPU which
honestly confused the heck out of me in
the early days when I was looking for a
cloud computing and I kept finding all
these graphics and I'm like why do
people want to use anyway it was really
confusing but that's why I mean the GPU
is just a superior large calculation
kind of device here so just for kicks
the number one supercomputer at least
that is known right the number one
publicly announced supercomputer is the
tianhe-2
which literally translates to skyriver
but really means Milky Way - this
performs at a peak of 33.86 petaflops
this is 33.86 quadrillion floating-point
operations per second so how do people
build these things well generally we
have two types of supercomputers in
existence you've got your clusters and
you've got your distributed systems
first let's talk about clusters this is
what you think of when you literally
think of a supercomputer clusters are
nodes that are really close to each
other usually like in the same
room and these are going to be more
efficient because there's no well
there's less bandwidth and latency
constraints slowing down data transfer
and sharing and they're generally
structured specifically for the job of
supercomputing then you have things like
distributed systems this is where you
have a network of computers spread
around hence distributed connected via
something like the Internet tcp/ip
generally distributed supercomputers are
far more lacs when it comes to
efficiency so you'll find many of these
distributed computers right our
supercomputers they're going to contain
everything you've got computers phones
tablets desktop netbooks laptops
whatever so folding at home is an
example of this massive distributed
supercomputer so one of the largest
distributed supercomputers but no one
near the largest is folding a home and
it pushes 18 head of flops or 18
quadrillion floating-point operations
per second that's pretty impressive and
this one is dedicated purely to science
and solving disease so supercomputers
can also be used for more malicious
things one of the largest targets for
governments and supercomputers is doing
things like cracking encryption so it's
somewhat likely that the NSA already has
a supercomputer that's more powerful
than 33.86 petaflops and we do know that
China is also working on a 100 petaflop
computer and it's also likely that China
themselves has another one that is
secret you know so supercomputers today
are a lot like nuclear weapons of the
past where a supercomputer capable of
shattering say something like 256 AES
encryption to a large degree would
render pretty much every business
insecure country's infrastructure
insecure you could do a lot of damage if
you had that much power luckily it's
unlikely that anyone does but
interestingly enough there is one
supercomputer that is by far the largest
supercomputer in the
world it's actually larger than every
supercomputer in the world put together
times 500 and still larger and it's
growing stronger and stronger every day
see I was doing some research and I'll
probably dedicate a video to this on
this on this topic specifically but I
will just mention it here last year
early 2013 the Bitcoin network surpassed
one exaflop pretty much unheard of as
China again is trying to finish their
100 petaflop and the NSA is probably got
something around 200 to 300 the Bitcoin
network passed one exaflop to 3/4 and
today the Bitcoin network is measured at
two hundred and eighty seven thousand
one hundred and fifty-eight peda flops
or 287 X of flops and growing and just
for measure it is February 2014 the
Bitcoin network is the largest
supercomputing network in history
outpacing all other known supercomputers
on the planet added together by far the
network is very unique as there is no
central server so normally the data and
all this stuff does come back to a
central place whereas the Bitcoin
networks actual purpose is to achieve
network consensus so it's almost like
the network's purpose is to be what a
central server would be yet not be a
central server so the idea here is that
there is no trusted third party or
anyone in control of it so anyway if
you're more interested in Bitcoin I
won't bother anybody too much with
Bitcoin and how it works in this video
but it's actually very impressive
invention but anyway I will probably put
out a video more about the size of the
Bitcoin network and what people really
should ought to be doing with the
Bitcoin network but they aren't so stay
tuned for that and the let's see the
last major part to the workings of a
supercomputer is you know how do we get
them to communicate with each other so
you can tie all your supercomputers
together and put them on the same local
area network
how do you actually get them to start
sharing processing jobs well this is
where the MPI comes in which stands for
a message passing interface so what MPI
does is it passes messages between the
nodes to keep them working in a
synchronized fashion on the same problem
and it allows us to share resources to
solve a problem so that satisfies the
basics of what a supercomputer is what
its purposes are and all that and on the
next video what we're going to be
talking about is how you can build your
very own supercomputer what you're going
to need and all that so hopefully that
sounds interesting to you guys as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support in the subscriptions and until
next time